apenas dos semanas después de que Moscú
reclamara ilegalmente la anexión de
gerson las evacuaciones ya han comenzado
las autoridades rusas citaron el jueves
a los ciudadanos de la estratégica
región a oír hacia el sur de Ucrania
mientras que sigue Rompiendo las líneas
del frente
tras el discurso del jefe de la región
ucraniana de gerson Vladimir saldon el
gobierno ruso ha tomado la decisión de
organizar la asistencia a las personas
que abandonan la región hacia otras
regiones del país proporcionaremos a
todos alojamiento gratuito y todo lo
necesario a los que deciden quedarse
permanentemente en su nuevo lugar se les
proporcionará un hogar
se ha informado de la primera llegada de
evacuaciones a la región rusa de rostov
mientras que otros se han dirigido a la
Península de crimea a pesar de Los
Fuertes bombardeos de Moscú como aquí en
la cercana ciudad de nicolife otras
cinco localidades de gerson han sido
retomadas por las fuerzas ucranianas y
el aluvión de ataques rusos en todo el
país No parece haber mermado la moral de
las tropas uc
y de equipos el hecho de que dejaran los
proyectiles y esparcieran solo parte de
la pólvora demuestra que huyeron muy
rápido
si nos movemos rápidamente habrá muchas
pérdidas no tenemos que apresurarnos
pero tenemos que aplastarlos hasta el
final
Mientras tanto en Moscú se está llevando
a cabo un esfuerzo propagandístico para
apuntalar el apoyo en casa aquí en
zaporilla se ha filmado a combatientes
por los rusos bien equipados
preparándose para el combate pero hasta
que los tiempos de miles de reservistas
movilizados por Moscú se han operativos
kiev tratará de mantener el ímpetu de su
contra ofensiva en el frente Sur